The global movement against free
trade and capitalism that first came
together at the 1999 protest
against the World Trade Organization
coalesced around the idea that
Western elites had led third world
nations to get ensnared in a debt
trap as a way to coerce them
into adopting neoliberal policies.
When poorer nations couldn't afford
to repay what they owed the World
Bank and the International Monetary
Fund, these Washington based
organizations agreed to restructure
the loans of debtor countries if
they would agree to move in the
direction of privatization,
deregulation and free trade.
A policy agenda termed "shock
therapy." Leftist leaders
like Hugo Chavez claimed that this
was part of a pattern of elite
subjugation of Latin America that
stretched all the way back to
Christopher Columbus.
Chavez used this as evidence in
support of Venezuela's turn
toward Cuba-style socialism.
Columbia
University's Joseph Stiglitz, a
former chief economist at the World
Bank and a Nobel Prize-winning
critic of free market capitalism,
promoted the same narratives.
He blamed the Washington consensus
for pushing policies he deemed too
radical and wrongheaded to ever get
through in the U.S.
What is your criticism of the
World Bank and the IMF
and all that they were doing?
In many ways, they were pursuing
policies, pushing
developing countries to have
policies that were very
different from the policies that
we were working for or supported
at home. I mean, for instance,
privatization of Social Security.
So like, generally speaking, IMF
programs are designed to prevent
Western-style social democracies.
They're designed to prevent free
health care and education.
They're designed to prevent even
modest subsidies on basic
goods.
Unlike Stiglitz, Alex Gladstein
identifies as a classical liberal
and the Human Rights Foundation,
where he works as chief strategy
officer, condemns the crimes
committed by socialist dictators
like Chavez.
Yet in his recent book, "Hidden
Repression: How the IMF and World
Bank so Exploitation is
Development," Gladstein argues that
the story told by the radical left
about these two organizations is
largely correct.
His work over the last few years
has focused heavily on monetary
colonialism, or how the US
and European nations use their
control of global currency to
override the sovereignty of the
poorer nations in Latin America
and Africa.
The fix, he says, is for
the world to transition to Bitcoin,
a form of freedom money that no
country or corporation can
manipulate or control.
Reason sat down with Gladstein at
the Miami Bitcoin Conference in May
to talk about his new book.
Why did you write Hidden Repression
and what is monetary colonialism and
why is it bad?
I wrote Hidden Repression because I
had a lot of questions about the IMF
and World Bank.
I
knew that a lot of people in the
Global South didn't like the IMF.
I knew that it had a bad reputation.
I didn't have the same view about
the World Bank, I felt like most
people talked about the World Bank
as maybe a neutral institution,
maybe had some issues, but generally
speaking, did good things.
But I started to kind
of just notice that they were tied
to certain practices
and certain phenomena that I was
writing about, most notably
monetary colonialism in West Africa.
I noticed that the IMF was kind of
an instrument that the French used
to kind of impose currency
devaluation on this subject,
post-colonial
countries there.
And I started to look around for
resources last summer, and I noticed
that there was no kind of pop econ
book about the IMF, that that
was approachable.
Like there's no "Big Short" for the
IMF.
There is nothing I mean, seriously,
there's really nothing.
There's. There's the shock doctrine
and there's like "Confessions
of an Economic Hitman," which are
just not really
what I needed.
You know, the second one is like,
highly exaggerated and who knows how
true it is.
And they're just they were very kind
of one-sided political texts.
So I just started to say,
all right, well, let me dig into
this. And I started to read
everything I could find online.
I fall back like lots of books,
tons of JSTOR articles,
a lot of credit to CI HUB.
Definitely support the Communists in
Kazakhstan who run CI HUB.
You can give them bitcoin to
get all this free articles that
otherwise are behind this like
insane firewall.
But just tons of like JSTOR articles
from the sixties and seventies and
eighties.
Lots of books written in the
eighties and nineties.
And then there's just like it just
sort of ended.